le conseil constitutionnel est il
suffisamment indépendant vis-à-vis du
gouvernement pour pouvoir continuer à se
prononcer après avoir validé la loi
sanitaire à les sages comme ils sont
appelés doivent désormais examiner la
très controversée loi sur le séparatisme
et sa batterie de mesures comme la
neutralité du service public la lutte
contre la haine en ligne l'encadrement
de l'instruction en famille le contrôle
renforcé des associations une meilleure
transparence des cultes et de leur
financement la lutte contre les
certificat de virginité la polygamie ou
encore les mariages forcés après sept
mois d'allers et retours entre le palais
bourbon et le sénat le texte respect des
principes de la république porté par le
ministre gérald darmanin a été adopté
par les députés dans l'indifférence
quasi générale le 23 juillet à 49 voix
pour 19 contre et 5 abstentions
dans un baroud d'honneur jean luc
mélenchon avait défendu en vain une
dernière motion de rejet préalable
contre une loi je cite dangereuse
antirépublicaine et à vocation
antimusulman vous faites une loi qui à
nos yeux est une loi inutile pour une
part d'entre elles puisqu'elles ne fait
que répéter ce qui existe déjà et pour
le reste dangereuse parce qu'elles
menacent les libertés mais surtout
parce qu'elle ouvre la porte à un
déferlement que nous ne connaissons que
trop et que nous jugeons néfastes
profondément à l'unité de la patrie qui
compte cinq à six millions de musulmans
qui sont nos compatriotes
nos parents souvent
nous allier toujours au total ils sont
plus de soixante députés et plus de
soixante sénateurs de gauche comme de
droite à avoir déposé un recours auprès
du conseil constitutionnel
et pour cause le projet de loi
s'attaquerait par petites touches aux
équilibres de la loi de 1905 protestants
catholiques juifs et musulmans dénoncent
loi qui met les cultes sous tutelle par
sa logique interne quoi qu'il en soit
des intentions ce projet de loi risque
de porter atteinte aux libertés
fondamentales que sont la liberté de
culte d'associations d'enseignement et
même à la liberté d'opinion malmené par
une police de la pensée qui s'installe
de plus en plus dans l'espace commun
nous nous interrogeons sur la visée de
ce texte et considérons que ces chances
d'améliorer la lutte contre les
séparatismes sont faibles les structures
associatives avec des moyens réduits
peine à mobiliser des acteurs bénévoles
pour assumer leurs missions ces
contraintes accrues peuvent aussi faire
fuir les plus intègres et laisser le
champ libre à des aventuriers les
extrémistes eux peuvent choisir de ne
pas utiliser les supports associatif le
renforcement des contrôles pourraient
être interprétées comme une suspicion
généralisée
je crains des effets collatéraux sur les
autres religions d'autant qu'il ya des
cultes qui ont été exemplaires depuis
toujours avec la république une
surenchère s'est installée au fil des
semaines le sénat est allé jusqu'à voter
des amendements sur l'interdiction des
prières dans l'enceinte des universités
du port de signes religieux pour les
personnes accompagnant elle est sortie
scolaire et les filles mineures ainsi
que du burkini dans les piscines
publiques mais il ya plus annie genevard
députés l ère du double a pour sa part
proposé d'interdire les danses
traditionnelles lors des mariages civils
accusant implicitement les populations
musulmanes de ne pas danser de manière
républicaine une proposition restée
lettre morte quoi qu'il en soit le texte
a fait l'objet de vives critiques à
travers le monde en turquie
particulièrement l'adoption de cette loi
qui est ouvertement en contradiction
avec les droits de l'homme la liberté de
religion et les valeurs européennes sera
un coup de guillotine infligé à la
démocratie française il est évident
qu'un tel projet de loi provoquera des
troubles au sein de la communauté turque
et des millions de musulmans nous
appelons les autorités françaises en
premier lieu le président macron à agir
avec bon sens le conseil constitutionnel
va t'il valider un texte qui remettent
en cause les fragiles acquis de la
laïcité de 1905
réponse ce vendredi